we had a guy on fear factor once that
was a professional rodeo guy and his
shoulder was like a topographic map it
was just he had so many scars in his
shoulder and he told me show that would
just pop out just like he could just pop
it out left but right from just being
destroyed like gored by both falling and
getting it ripped apart all riding bulls
yeah yeah I just I just don't get that
it just wasn't working anymore I mean he
had a bunch of surgeries and they tried
to screw it back together and tighten
things down but it was just destroyed
I'm sure I'm sure a bull rider would
look at free soloing and people like
what a crazy do you know everybody looks
at another sport I like that's great and
honestly I look at fighting and I'm like
duh seems totally outrageous like why
would you want some other dude beating
you to death in a cage like that's it's
great outrageous it is outrageous but if
you can get good enough or you can avoid
yeah getting seen on damage yeah and
then the tool and the damage it's kind
of the same but even landing the damage
to a certain extent you're like oh
you're hurting somebody else for the
pleasure of the crowd you're like that's
kind of messed up yeah you know it's a
very weird feeling knocking someone out
is one of the weirdest feelings because
part of you is happy that it's not you
but part of you is like looking down
with that guy that's just got flatlined
and you're like whoa that could have
been made how much the fighters like
hold back you know because I feel like
you kind of have to be like go to the
death but then if you actually like
punch somebody so hard they died or
something I mean obviously you'd feel
horrible right well you don't suck back
at all but that's not saying but so it's
like you don't hold back at all but then
if you actually killed somebody wouldn't
you feel horrible it's very rare that
someone dies in mixed martial arts
believe it or not well yeah no I mean I
know that but it's possible and it has
happened and it's sort of like it has
happened very very rarely in mixed
martial arts never in the UFC but in
boxing it happens more often and with
one of the reasons why it happens more
often in boxing because you're only
punching in MMA you're taking people
down yeah people are tapping out because
they're paying we're crazy yeah well
it's also there's more options to defend
yourself
you're not just getting battered against
the ropes they're also nowadays much
better at stopping a fight when a
fighter is clearly compromised
they're really [ __ ] up in the old days
they used to let guys just get battered
they used to you know that doesn't sit
well with me I'm just like oh yeah but
that's not I'm not a fighter
well it's like that's the thing about
this thing about climbing is there's
this real elemental appeal to just you
in the mountain and its nature and it's
beautiful and it's like very peaceful
and calm it's like so different than
having thousands of people screaming at
you as you punch them down the face over
and over just like dude that's just
that's not my scene
well did you see the Conor McGregor
khabib nurmagomedov fight where there's
a bigger fight outside the cage oh is
that the thing where the guy bolts out
of the cage and like starts brawling or
I was like yeah it's like WWE or
whatever it's like when they start
breaking tables over people crazier than
that because it was real oh yeah I was
like this is totally outrageous but
what's funny is it became chaos because
a fight erupted outside of the
parameters of the fight it was just more
fighting yeah it seen fighting yeah like
this is what we paid for this isn't okay
right everybody it's like fighting in
the cage fine this is lovely but he
comes out of the cage oh my god he's out
in the wild that's like out in the world
fighting isn't that got a messed up yeah
it's definitely mad feel like he's a
professional fighter he's fighting like
that's what he does it's weird that's
the whole listen this is coming from
someone who's been involved in this my
whole life it's weird it's I absolutely
see all the arguments against it and yet
you still want to go traitor punch
people in the face well I don't punch
anybody in the face anymore I still
choke people but